[Musique]
jetons
google a présenté lors de sa conférence
deux nouveaux modèles de nouveaux
smartphones j'en avais déjà parlé à
l'époque des rumeurs c'est le google
pixels 3 avec bulkypix 1,3 à ixelles
alors si vous vous souvenez
l'année dernière c'était au mois
d'octobre s'agit pas de bêtises google
nous a présenté deux nouveaux
smartphones et des premiers smartphones
en tout cas qui arrivait sur le marché
français puis dans beaucoup d'autres
pays d'un monde entier google pixels 3
google pixels 3xl deux modèles plutôt
intéressant bien j'adore mais en tout
cas le groupe xl 3g utilisé pendant
longtemps avant de changer pour suivre
l'actualité et un peu moins le google
pixels 3xl à cause de sa grande encoches
smartphone très sympa très pratique très
agréable néanmoins à ce que j'aimais pas
là dessus c'était vraiment une coche et
ça c'est bien en tout cas il est
supprimée sur le google pixels 3a
il scelle alors google un vrai problème
a eu en tout cas un problème avec ses
modèles haut de gamme pour plusieurs
raisons quand je dis problème c'est que
les ventes n'ont pas été à la hauteur
des ambitions fait déjà cramé problème
c'est qu'une concurrence qui est très
forte et très bien implanté dans le haut
de gamme dans le premium
les clients qui vont vers des produits
premium vont plus vers des produits
qu'ils ont déjà pu tester par le passé
et donc des produits ou une vraie
antériorité et là pour le coup c'était
le premier produit je pense notamment
sur le marché français le google pixels
3 pixels 3xl et il faut le reconnaître
un design relativement old school et
surtout cette grande encoches sur l'udc
celle qui est elle vraiment pas terrible
alors pour ces produits on a un os qui
complètement optimisé
on a une qualité photo qui est vraiment
incroyable de la même manière on a un
écran qui vraiment d'une excellente
qualité on a un son qui est top avec des
haut-parleurs stéréo on a des
performances avec le qualcomm snapdragon
845 maintenant le point négatif c'est
l'autonomie
le pixel 3 vous gardez une journée pas
plus pour avoir un peu plus d'autonomie
il faut aller sur le pixel 3xl avec les
pixels 3 et les pixels 3xl google
s'attaque à une nouvelle cible toujours
exigeante dans un segment encore plus
concurrentiel qu'est le milieu de gamme
avec énormément de marques et il a rien
aucune proposition de valeur qu'il
affaire extrêmement mal le top en photo
à moins de 400 euros
alors je vous montre s'est produit j'ai
pas en ma possession ou encore les
google pixels 3 mpixels 3xl restera plus
tard dont je vous invite dès maintenant
vous abonner comme ça vous saurez tout
mais j'ai déjà pu voir pas mal de chose
de sûr regarder des vidéos
aux deux confrères de potes et
franchement ils ont l'air vraiment bien
parce qu'un point qui est majeur
aujourd'hui pour l'achat d'un smartphone
c'est la partie photo google vous
connaissez historiquement ils sont très
forts dans le point de vue logiciel avec
une armée d'ingénieurs développeurs
codeurs en tout genre ils ont beaucoup
de monde qui travaillent derrière sur la
partie software
autant vous dire qu'il ya une vraie
armée derrière et qu'il est très
difficile de venir chercher google sur
la partie logicielle que ce soit sans
pixel 3 pixels 3xl ou alors pixels 3a ou
pixel 3 à ixelles souvent la concurrence
fait le point fort sur la partie
matérielle avec un zoom périscopique
avec des caméras de saïfi en d'ailerons
de requins comme sur le haut-pont rénaux
il ya pas mal de propositions de valeur
différents qui sont très intéressantes
google va pas du tout là-dessus propose
aux smartphones qui est assez
minimaliste du point de vue matériel en
tout cas il n'y a pas d'innovation de
choses qui se lèvent de tous les côtés
par contre du point de vue logiciel ils
sont strictement imbattable et ils l'ont
démontré avec le pixel 3 pixels 3xl avec
un seul objectif ils font des photos de
malades
y a qu'à regarder leurs sites pour s'en
rendre compte là vous avez les nouveaux
pixels 3a il ya vraiment que la partie
logicielle sur lequel il ya un gros
focus qui est fait des jaloux de marque
tout ce qui vous plaît chez google dans
un téléphone nous tous qui nous plaît
single cry le général c'est plutôt la
partie logicielle on descend vous allez
voir on arrive directement paf sur les
photos ça c'est très très très gros
point fort de ce smartphone la vision du
donc toujours photo pixels 3a
on arrive tac mode portrait on continue
effet de profondeur donc l'effet ben ok
on arrive ensuite sur les effets de
couleur en continu stockage illimité
donc là on est pareil sur google claude
donc on reste vraiment dans l'univers de
google avec en bas yves houle marque
google photos on continue de descendre
live ou pas d'autonomie donc c'est
vraiment mélange entre la partie
logicielle et la partie matérielle pour
le coup on descend une journée complète
d'autonomie pour ça on va le voir bien
évidemment parce que les batteries sont
pas énormes ça j'ai voulu exposer dans
quelques temps de la recharge rapide et
l'a dit à google ce qu'il à faire là il
vous parle tout de suite bien évidemment
vous l'avez compris de google assistant
montcourt est vraiment dans la partie
logicielle google la sécurité et l'ordre
parle un peu de matériel avec les puces
titan m
on continue et on arrive sur les
couleurs du matériel hockey et ensuite
sur l'ensemble de l'écosystème google
google maps google agenda j'aimais
chrome compagnie je voulais pas secousse
est bien évidemment youtube
donc on le voit ici google nous parle
vraiment plus de logiciels que le
matériel parce que c'est leur coeur de
métier c'est leur savoir faire qui est
maîtrisé et c'est là dessus qu'ils vont
vraiment se distinguer des autres
épatant par des ied qui est somme toute
un peu plus classique je vous présentais
les promus de côté un peu de technique
mais juste avant j'ai des tarifs très
intéressants
le pixel 3 est disponible à moins de 400
euros à 399 euros
c'est un tarif qui est extrêmement
agressif alors il ya des concessions
encore été faite que vous les précisions
quelques instants tandis que le pixel 3
à ixelles et à 479 euros pour info le
guen pixels 3 coûte 859 euros et le
pixel 3 à ixelles 959 l'euro donc il ya
une vraie différence de prix entre ces
produits qui sont dans le premium et les
12 autres qui sont dans le milieu de
gamme et vous allez voir en terme de
photos on a gardé les sens de ce
smartphone on a gardé la partie
logicielle derrière des quelques
modifications du point de vue matériel
qui justifie cette différence de prix
mais franchement à mon avis j'ai hâte de
tester à 12
on va toujours mettre un peu des
guillemets parce qu'on le testera ses
plus forts le feed back chez certains
copains journalistes
et puis vous assurer qu'ils vont dire
juste énorme en photo premier point et
non des moindres d'un point de vue
design bull a déjà supprimé la grosse
encoches moche qu'on avait sur le google
pixels 3xl sur le pixel 3xl vous avez le
même form factor que ce soit pixels 3
juste un peu plus grands un peu plus
large
mais dans l'absolu c'est sensiblement la
même chose on a donc un pixel 3a qui
pèse 145 grammes et un pixel 3xl qui
pèse 165 grammes qui en font des
smartphone relativement léger qui sont
disponibles toujours les mêmes couleurs
le blanc et le noir multipuces technique
et j'ai pas encore tout appris par coeur
au niveau des écrans sur le google
pixels 3 on a d'écran de 5,6 pouces avec
une résolution de 2220 par 1080 pixels à
441 accède par pouce avec un ratio 18-25
9e tandis que sont google et celle 3 à
ixelles vous avez un écran de 6 pouces
avec une résolution de 2560 parmi les 80
pixels à 402 pixels par pouce et un
ratio de 18 9e
dans les deux cas c'est un écran oled on
va garder la même qualité qu'on a
actuellement ce nouvel pixels 3 et
gothique ces 3 xl côté audio ressert
toujours les haut parleurs stéréo ça
c'est franchement bien sauf que cette
fois ci on à la prise d acte qui fait
son apparition prise jack 3.5 c'est
assez surprenant parce que on voit que
les constructeurs en règle générale vont
supprimer la
jack pour proposer des technologies plus
modernes du bluetooth 5.0 pour aller se
connecter avec un casque à réduction
brute leboutou 5.0 on l'a quand même
dans ses smartphones par contre il
concerne la prise jack
l'idée de go derrière ça c'est vous dire
sera segment milieu de gamme sur les
smartphones ou autour de 400 euros c'est
déjà beaucoup d'argent les clients pas
forcément être équipés de casques à
l'adduction bruit donc on leur propose
une prise jack pour qu'ils puissent
brancher leur casque filaire voile un
peu l'idée derrière ça du point de vue
performances on n'est bien évidemment
pas sur un stade ragon 845 et encore
moins à 855 on est sur un qualcomm
snapdragon quand 70
côté graphique c'est une adreno 615 il
tourne avec 4 gigas de ram et à 64 giga
de stockage non extensible par contre
profité de google photo illimité pour
stocker toutes vos photos et toutes vos
vidéos
l'autonomie c'était vraiment point de
regret ce nouvel pixels 3 parce que
c'est une journée
et des fois pas forcément une journée
avoir sur ses smartphones je me pose un
peu la question parce qu'on a une
batterie de 3000 millan paire eur / le
pixel 3 à essoyes pixels 3xl vous avez
une batterie de 3700 milliards erreur
l'autonomie sera bien évidemment
meilleur sur pixels 3 à ixelles
à voir maintenant si on tient une
journée une journée et demie ça on en
reparlera lors des phases de test
à noter que vous avez de la recharge
rapide 18 watts et de la recherche bien
évidemment en usb tilt c'est l'ouest
bien évidemment c'est de l'eau est
purement google c'est un androïde neuf
failles et google nous promet derrière
trois ans mise à jour de sécurité donc
ça c'est aussi un excellent point
maintenant le point le plus intéressant
pour moi c'est la partie photo google
nous propose à l'arrière un capteur de
12,2 mégapixels avec une ouverture de f
1.8 avec un pixel qui fait 1,4 micron
pour joue pas ce truc hein vous à la
technologie dual pixels vous avez la
stabilisation optique et la
stabilisation électronique vous avez un
angle de vision de 76 degrés ici il ya
eu un compromis qu'a dû être fait pas de
grand temps que ce soit à l'arrière où
que ce soit à l'avant
en tout cas est vraiment intéressant sur
les google cars 7 3 6 et 3 xl de l'autre
côté on est sur les smartphones qui sont
quasiment moitié prix donc il faut
obliger moments forts à plus de coupes
franches pour gagner un petit peu en
termes de budget et à l'avant vous avez
une caméra de 8 mégapixels une ouverture
de f 2.0
il ya forcément une différence entre les
gaules pixels 3 inoue pixels 3 à la
différence va se faire comme je vous dis
déjà du fait que vous n'ayez pas de
grand angle ça ça change un petit peu
l'histoire parce que le sel fille grand
angle j'adorais vous est rentré planons
d'intérieur ça c'était là le premier
point le fait que vous n'ayez pas
d'autofocus en mouvement et le sexe pas
possible d'avoir le portrait groupe au
delà de ça vous avez un appareil photo
qui devrait vous permettre de
d'excellentes photos que ce soit en
condition nuit que ce soit en condition
du jour un truc vraiment optimisé j'ai
déjà vu des rendus trouve ça vraiment
intéressant et j'ai hâte pour assister
donc une fois de plus david est
maintenant à vous abonner comme ça on en
reparlera ensemble dans quelques jours
c'est un smartphone qui comme je voulais
dire du bluetooth 5.0 à du nfc est
vraiment bien à tout d'un grand
un petit prix sera pas aussi performant
et pourra pas faire autant de choses
demain qu'un google pixels 3 est un
excellent 3 x est parce que derrière
vous tournez pas sur le dernier soc de
qualcomm vous n'avez pas une machine qui
est top de performance par contre à mon
avis pour tout ce qui va être jeux
réseaux sociaux photo photo est énorme
bien évidemment on va le tester mais
connaissant google
à mon avis la machine elle va être
vraiment hard et surtout pour son prix à
moins de 400 euros sont pixels 3a et à
479 euros sont pixels 3xl ça va vraiment
faire hyper mal dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez
est ce que vous avez acheté le pixel 3 à
6 et 3 xl est ce que vous vous êtes dit
ces smartphones ont l'air vraiment
intéressant par contre à 8 cents et
quelques et 900 échec je préfère aller
sur un autre produit de chez samsung
huawei apple est ce si bon voilà on
verra plus tard peut-être
et est-ce que vous sur l'idée d'un
smartphone milieu de gamme vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter
parce qu'à mon avis en termes de footeux
dans le milieu de gamme ils vont faire
extrêmement mal à toute la concurrence
dites moi ce que vous en pensez est ce
qu'ils peuvent vous tentez wind on vous
a dit bien évidemment à rester connectés
parce qu'on reparle dans quelques jours
de ses smartphones on va les tester ça
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
d'ici là je vous embrasse son message et
prenez soin de vous ciao